I haven't never cheated on him during my  marriage that's not who I am  keshia knight pulliam emotionally opened  up to et's Michelle Turner earlier this  week she tearfully addressed her  estranged husband Edie  Hart wells decision to file for divorce  and request a paternity test just one  week after she revealed she was  expecting a child I've never been  unfaithful to my husband that this is  his daughter  now Hartwell is revealing his side of  the story here's what he told page six  on Thursday Keisha says she's never been  unfaithful do you is she lying or say  she stayed out she's not home  she's went out of town three days I  don't see that baby honestly I just want  to make sure that it isn't I'm not  saying that she's a bad person the  former NFL linebacker also explained the  couple simply had different priorities  she was adamant she ain't what she want  she  you